how exactly did Kabul make himself
faster than a speeding bullet and more
powerful than a locomotive the actor
turned to the exclusive gym known for
training athletes military personnel and
the cast of 300. the gym Prides itself
on having no televisions and no machines
and no mirrors and no comfortable places
to sit cavill's training regimen
essentially pushed him into the realm of
the Superhuman he explained I'm training
two and a half hours a day pushing my
body Beyond its normal limits it's not
just a physical thing but a
psychological thing as well one of
caval's favorite ways to stay in shape
is by practicing Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
however the actor doesn't just dabble in
the martial arts he trains with the best
caval frequently takes lessons from
10-time Jujitsu world champion hodger
Gracie in an Instagram post he wrote my
bjja slipped by the wayside a bit with
my focus being on work but it's now time
to get back into it such an enjoyable
way to train